Successful companies
don't invest in talent
so the competition can hire them away.
They keep their people motivated
to grow with the company
and inspire those around them
to lean in with them.
I believe that talent retention,
the same tool used to grow
successful companies,
can be used to build great neighborhoods
for the people born and raised in them.
My hometown is the South Bronx
in New York City,
(Cheers)
holla --
(Applause)
And it’s the kind of neighborhood
that, some might say,
actually has a talent repulsion strategy.
Back in the 1980s,
I walked by this crack house
on the way to the subway
that would take me to my high school,
one of the best in the country,
the Bronx High School of Science.
Alright, figured there'd be at least
some of you in here.
Neighborhoods like mine are places
where inequality is assumed
by the people who live there
and by everyone else
on the outside looking in.
These are places where the schools,
public health, air and water,
parks and trees, food options,
career opportunities are worse
than in other parts of the same town.
Government subsidized rental housing
and health clinics,
homeless shelters, liquor stores,
dollar stores predominate.
Few banks,
but plenty of check cashing stores
or pawnshops that charge you
to use the money you may have.
I refer to these communities
as low-status.
I don’t call them poor
or underprivileged because frankly,
status implies something
larger and deeper at work
and that inequality
is a well-established fact.
Think of the communities
like that near you.
They're everywhere, they're inner cities,
they're reservations,
white Rust Belt towns
and all over the world.
And bright kids who grow up in them
are expected to measure success
by how far they get away from them.
I was one of those kids,
and now I’m a real estate developer
and strategy consultant.
And I work nationally,
but the South Bronx is my research
and development laboratory,
where I actually practice
restorative community development.
And that same corner
that was once a crack house
is now the home of my hip hop cafe --
award-winning hip hop cafe --
excuse me,
The Boogie Down Grind.
(Applause and cheers)
And it's two blocks away
from the house I grew up in
and around the corner
from where I live right now.
So I have embraced my inner capitalist
and my inner socialist
and my inner libertarian
among a bunch of other things, however.
But I'd like to talk now
about how capitalism,
and the spirit behind it,
and it's application,
that's what determines its outcomes.
US capitalism supported slavery.
And it's supported Black Wall Streets,
those communities
of Black folks formerly enslaved
or just one generation out of it.
And where they built great businesses
and wealth and communities.
And the most famous of which
was the town of Greenwood
in Tulsa, Oklahoma.
Black Wall Streets were destroyed,
burned down,
and the Black people in them murdered
by white mobs, savagely
and without consequence.
Now was that capitalism's fault
or some kind of white cultural flaw?
Or distinction that has gone
unaddressed to this day?
Now, I know some people
don't like hearing about it,
but imagine what it feels like
to experience it.
I mean, America has had a talent
retention strategy
or something like it in place since 1619.
Slavery provided white Americans
with all the benefits of that barbaric
and predatory industry.
And although Black Wall Streets were built
on the sustainable ideals of life,
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and property ownership,
Black Wall Streets were destroyed
because the people
who built them were not white.
Same system, very different outcomes.
Citigroup estimates
that the racial wealth gap in the US
has actually cost us 16 trillion dollars
over the last 20 years alone.
Now, let's just think
about that for just a moment,
the money that could have gone
into the economy but didn't
because of systemic racism that defined
who benefited from America's growth.
There's no need to reinvent
the wheel here.
If we want to make America
as good as its promise,
then we should apply the same tools
of capitalism that built white wealth
to build wealth in low-status communities.
Especially --
(Applause)
Especially in terms of property ownership
and real estate development,
because real estate development
in low-status communities in the US
currently takes one of two paths.
You know, first, poverty maintenance,
wherein you'll see things like
the concentration of things,
such as health clinics
and government subsidized housing,
excuse me, rental housing,
pharmacies, philanthropic
and government dollars pour in,
and the nonprofit industrial complex
seems to view poverty
sort of as an authentic
cultural attribute of the area.
And thus you'll see all sorts of programs
that are designed to sort of
manage that poverty,
but the communities do not improve.
Money will be made, lots of it,
but not for the local people.
And in fact, one can view many
of the well-intentioned programs
as talent extraction,
because the promising talent is encouraged
to grow up and be somebody,
but certainly not in their own hood.
(Applause)
And the other type
is gentrification displacement.
When urban populations grow,
even some politicians
and even some activists
will resist greater density.
So you have rising demand
and limited supply.
And then prices go up.
And gentrification generally means
outsiders coming in to a community
in order to build one that suits
their needs and their desires,
and it's not for the needs
and desires of the people
that are already in that community.
But let's just be real,
it's not always mutually exclusive,
because people in those communities
want nice things, too.
They do.
And that's why they leave
whenever they can
in order to experience them.
So capitalism can fuel
gentrification and displacement
or poverty maintenance,
but neither of these
strategies actually help,
the people in those communities live
in the kind of neighborhoods
that we all deserve.
What if we looked
at low-status communities
as though they were struggling companies?
How would we turn them around?
How would a talent retention model work
on a neighborhood scale?
So municipalities, they hand out
corporate retention deals
because they believe that the economic
activity that it will produce
is actually worth the subsidy
that they pay out.
And so we'll need to do the same thing
in low-status communities
for the people that were led to believe
that they need to measure success
by how far they get away
from those places.
You know, we can't really
force anybody to stay,
but we can nudge them
with lifestyle infrastructure,
the type of stuff that we learned
through our own market research
that people told us that they wanted.
Places like cafes and bars and bookstores
and farmer's markets and, you know,
the places that, frankly,
you probably all like to go to, too.
They build positive community interactions
and make people feel really cool.
So another nudge would be real
access to property ownership
and business ownership
that keeps people vested
in their neighborhoods.
These are like benefits, you know,
and company stock options,
so when the community does well,
so do the residents.
It's kind of like the employees
of a hot start-up.
So how do we make sure
that these benefits and stock options
get in the right hands and appreciate
and value for them?
Now in the US,
if you're accused of a crime
and can't afford legal counsel,
a public defender will be assigned to you.
The same can be done
for local property owners.
Before a real estate transaction goes
forward within a low-status community,
the seller should receive quality
legal and financial counsel,
so they are fully aware
of the value of their land
and how they could maximize it
through sensible refinancing,
by building, you know,
vertical additions for rentals
and also accessory dwelling units
and also using the value
to do sensible refinancing,
put their kids through
college, build a business.
You know, or maybe,
you know, property owners
might even be considered a protected class
by the United States Securities
and Exchange Commission
in order to protect
Black wealth in particular
and other low-status community wealth
from the continuing liquidation
that they still deal with.
Because it is common for people
who do own property
in low-status communities
to be approached all the time
for quick cash offers.
These are actual solicitations
that I've received at my home.
These can be very enticing to people
who have never been led to believe
that there's any real value
in their community.
And the thing is, it's all legal.
And real estate companies, big and small,
as well as private equity,
have done a very effective job
of increasing wealth inequality in the US
by separating financially unsavvy people
from any hope of generational
wealth potential.
So, you know --
(Applause)
The SEC recently proposed new rules
requiring businesses to report
their greenhouse gas emissions
in an effort to increase transparency
of the risk to its investors.
Maybe they should do
the same thing for taxpayers.
We know real estate
and private equity firms
can engage in predatory practices
at the expense of taxpayers
by privatizing the profits
and socializing the costs.
And this is because a business model
that reduces opportunities
for home ownership
also creates more landless renters,
exacerbates the concentration of poverty,
and statistically increases
poverty's ill effects,
including higher rates
of bad policing and incarceration
and lower health and educational outcomes.
Their message shut out aspiring homeowners
from the American dream.
It comes at a cost to all of us,
and so it should come
at a far greater cost
to those who do business like that.
Another issue is that some renters
actually pay more in rent
than they would on a mortgage.
But most of us
who actually need a mortgage
cannot compete with the speed
at which predatory speculators
show up with all-cash deals.
Period.
A possible solution is for philanthropic
organizations to buy properties
at market value from those
who actually choose to sell --
once they’re fully aware
of what they’re selling ...
and then hold them
so that other folks within the communities
have the time
to get financing and then buy.
That's a valuable cushion
of time for people,
and it gives people a chance
to participate in the American dream.
And it's a low-risk place to park capital.
These are some examples
of just how we can build
a restorative economic
approach to capitalism.
It's still capitalism,
but with rules and practices
that favor the outcomes
that we need as a nation.
But folks on the ground,
they are not waiting.
They're absolutely not waiting.
In West Oakland, California,
third generation
West Oaklander Noni Session
leads the East Bay Permanent
Real Estate Cooperative.
They have recently acquired
property collectively
to build a permanent, affordable,
mixed-use real estate development
that benefits its resident owners.
The cooperative offers these
lunchtime learning sessions
so people can fully understand things
about investment and development.
And their current membership includes
about 500 community, investor,
resident and staff owners.
And they have, to date,
raised five million dollars
for their community, landing
and housing fund.
(Applause)
In Philadelphia, a community
development program called Jumpstart,
started by Ken Weinstein.
He’s a commercial real estate developer,
and the program provides training,
mentoring and loans
to aspiring local residential developers,
mostly women and people of color.
Since 2015, they’ve trained
more than 2,500 people,
more than 350 loans
totaling more than 40 million dollars
that have actually rehabbed
more than 350 units,
had been totally rehabilitated.
Their respective activities
actually improve the value
of each other's properties.
And they're reducing blight in Philly
neighborhood by neighborhood,
from the inside out.
Jumpstart's now in more
than 13 communities around the country.
And Dune Lankard is a member
of the Eyak tribe in Alaska.
And what he's working on
is securing livelihoods
for aspiring Native youth and women,
you know, where he's from.
And he's doing it through kelp farming
in ancestral native waters.
Kelp is a traditional
food source, number one,
and it also has important commercial
components in bioplastics,
in pharmaceuticals.
And also they use it
as an additive in cow feed
to reduce the methane in it.
I mean, it's amazing what it could do.
But he is competing
against multinational companies
to actually own a piece of this emerging
ocean industry for his people.
He's going to be up against it,
but he's got to be doing this.
It's so important.
And in the South Bronx,
there's this historic rail station,
that brought my daddy,
who was a Pullman porter,
into the neighborhood
where I was born and raised.
Back in the 1940s, it was even harder
to get a mortgage while Black.
And he won 15,000 dollars in a horse race
and carried it in a satchel
back across the country
and purchased a home
near that rail station for his family.
And that rail station has recently been
acquired by his baby daughter, me,
who is --
(Applause and cheers)
transforming it into a multi-use
performance venue,
an event hall for music and weddings
and quinceañeras and gaming tournaments.
And I ...
(Applause and cheers)
I am the manifestation of my mommy
and daddy's wildest dreams.
(Applause and cheers)
I'm not saying that talent retention
is going to solve all the problems
associated with poverty maintenance
or displacement and gentrification,
or solve all the wrongs of capitalism.
But I know we are not going to solve
any of those problems without it.
We don't have to keep building monuments
that honor the shameful practices
that created the inequality
that low status-communities experience.
If we use the tools
of capitalism that we have,
but in a much more restorative way,
we can help people
in low-status communities show
that you don't have to move
out of our neighborhoods
to live in better ones.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)